attention il dépose bisou qui traîne à
aulas ne l'ait pas fait à rio maintenant
il y avait jacques était là bas tant il
vient ni viennent de se marier
message même tout le monde ce jeune
nathan mais j'aurais voulu voir ça avec
anne parillaud je te jure vient de se
marier anne parillaud quand même enfin
laurent non mais c'était pas te balader
comme j'ai pas là
marc soit un peu tendu un les parties
avant l avantage ispa je sais pas tu
penses que fauchant 10 l'article de
paris match
ça pue cette devise éternelle gallopin
bah oui quand c'était beau c'est beau
séduire n fera en même temps ça vous
gêne quand on dit du bien de vous non
vous pouvez continuer c'est un peu
mouillé la chemise pour servir audi
vraiment n'importe quoi elles seraient
bien sûr rattrape toi ses parents vont
bon se connaître alors l'honneur par wal
ihsane qu'elle est beaucoup plus en
frais thierry mais alors pourquoi pas
franche pas alors on ira à bègles en
voyage de noces
mais qu'on soit un couple médiatique ça
vous gêne 3 dans un lit
vous assumez brawn sexualité vous me
ferez pas où dormir ce soir qu'est ce
qui attire ici savament et chocolat et
la peintre bleus
on s'entend bien tous les trois laurent
non
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu